at the end of the day we were just
outperformed out schemed they had an
answer for everything people saying well
why a't you go to linebacker guess what
the packages are in for me to go to
linebacker I can only play what it's
called I'm not putting out Personnel
I've even told multiple players coaches
that I'm very fine playing linebacker in
playoffs if that's what y'all want me to
do I just want to win I do see a Super
Bowl in my future I want to be a Super
Bowl champion I challenge anyone to
actually go look at the game film and
say did M could play his heart out to go
out like that at home was completely
embarrassing and unacceptable it took me
a while to even be able to show my face
in the
public